[Music]
[Laughter]
we're going to talk about the Space Jam
sequel starring LeBron James we're going
to talk about the fact that Ashton
Kutcher hit a teenager with his Tesla
but first watch this video this comes to
us from cu-boulder where the mascot
chipped the Buffalo shot himself in the
groin with a t-shirt cannon Oh baby
let's watch that one more time this is a
gift to us from the internet guy just
what you want mascot t-shirt gun in the
groin oh my god right in the Rocky
Mountain Oysters but don't worry we're
allowed to watch it because roll that
next clip he's okay look at him still
wait that's okay I think he's trying to
signal from inside the Hat like go
faster please
my nuts have been exploded chip the
Buffalo we're rooting for you we don't
know that that's the that's the same
chip I'm good guys that could be any
chip that's why I think this is like the
greatest way to embarrass yourself
because no one knows who's inside the
head and this man will forever know that
he did that but nobody he'll still be
able to like hang out yeah I was buzzy
the beat yeah it was like a low tier
mascot wait what was the matter so it
wasn't for the sports teams it was for
all the clubs like the trivia events
well here's the thing they they let me
have free range of what I wasn't because
no one cared so I would dress up and I
would hand out flyers and then I would
like go to the cafeteria I'd like
pretend to eat oh my god the JV mascot I
think that's saying like that's saying
it nicely truly no one like would wear
it and I'd be like hell where was this
high school this was college dude
juries anything like what I mean the
netting is really I would feel very
cross-eyed by the end of it so I'm not
surprised oh well when you get injured
if you can do it with a smile like this
next guy did in this next story so this
teenager got hit by a Tesla that
happened to be being driven by Ashton
Kutcher the cut check out that headline
and then no guilty well he got away with
it because right as he was on the ground
he said will you take a photo with me on
the floor Emilio merengue posted this to
his Instagram did he make the right move
or should he have tried to get more out
of this than just an instant wait what
he did not make the right move yeah you
should have got money really late we
started the morning meeting like two
hours ago oh sorry sorry sorry I think
we've been explained yeah I was just
stunned on you because the game would
Ryan is that everyone hates him okay
okay we've been in Los Angeles dude oh
we were just talking about a story he's
a teenager who got hit by a Tesla being
driven by Ashton Kutcher oh did you
get a tattoo oh yeah
I'm little I got a little few ones right
here like a symbol for like people
always wanting you to be like what they
think you should be okay and I'm just
gonna say like nah I'm just gonna be me
this is your true self I think we've
been in LA too long look like you fell
asleep and Jared Leto's closet dude
you're funny okay well right so funny we
need to keep doing this discussion so
Jordan you have any opinions about
Ashton Kutcher hitting a teenager on a
scooter with his Tesla buddy oh it's all
chill that's good man okay they're in
the photo together that's fine if he's
gonna take advantage of someone I don't
think I think taking advantage of
someone is like how is that better why
should he
she got hit by a car already got a hit
playing Jesus Christ I got love taps
Ashton Kutcher should not have hit
someone with his car yeah but he was
pulling out of the studio so I think the
kid was going over an open garage door
so he was in the wrong you have the the
car gets the right of way I don't want
to be a dick no when you're pulling out
it like car drives a lot of times it'll
say watch out for cars because they
can't see you I think it just says I
gotta be careful when you're parking you
can't close your eyes and be like I got
that right away
idiots all right you're all gonna get
hit by cars you like your driving I can
tell the universe is just chaos right so
it's like neither it's a little tight on
this couch dude okay you I want to talk
about Space Jam so this was a little
movie that came out in the 90s starring
Michael Jordan and they cartoon aliens
playing basketball they're remaking it
with LeBron James and I'm very excited
oh no I'm excited it's really happening
what's happening in the 50th episode I
for one am very excited check out this
tweet from the Spring Hill entertainment
production company this is how they
announced it we've got Bugs Bunny
postcards LeBron James small forward
Ryan Coogler producing and Terrance
Nance
directing how do we feel I'm excited
excited yeah I want to see Space Jam -
I'm looking forward to taking a flight
and watching it there I'm happy they're
redoing it because Space Jam 1 is a bad
movie and all of this horseshit about
everyone thinks it's like it should
become like one of these nostalgia like
isn't it so you know I'm interesting
because I like Space Jam you know it's
one of those things and so well I'm very
interesting and I love space I like
space damn I agree that it's a bad movie
but I love it because it's my bamboo
all right it's my childhoods bad movie
and plus Michael Jordan it's time I mean
he was great it is time for him to go
and LeBron to move in as legit King Jim
was one of the first things I remember
seeing as a kid in America sorry like
haha so that's what you think America is
like yeah this is incredible
humans are hanging out with cartoon dad
we escaped Russia and we did a good job
no one on line has been like oh my god
they're making another Space Jam you're
ruining my childhood and as we know
people say that about ever every
instance that they cannot remaking it's
a sequel I think it's the next well in
the future
no people hated that they made
ghostbusters again people that's why
it's gonna be super fun I love the first
one I'm I'm glad to see LeBron
dethroning Michael Jordan Nate what you
said about woman isn't cool woman what
about the woman about Ghostbusters that
was actually a beautiful film starring
Ogier smart woman when he came back
[Music]
that's why it was a good movie because
people are excited Space Jam is coming
back well you see it Hannah yes I will
see it I don't believe that for a second
any Marvel movie you're gonna hate what
amazes Bugs Bunny play basketball yeah I
will
that song is incredible that's it Bruno
Mars should do the new soundtrack they
should make the movie if he's not doing
the sound file didn't agree I just said
blue Branagh has a better acting coach
than Michael Jordan
okay actor he likes it better Mike
Michael Jordan at every facet open to
school in Rome and I like that about him
so I like it better for highly educated
you could learn acting at the school he
built that's true Jordan you know
waiting yet what do you think yeah yeah
thank you Nathaniel
yes Space Jam sequel in the with LeBron
James is actually happening and Ryan
Coogler is attached you know him from
Black Panther what do you guys think he
just introduced the discussion section
again we already
been talking about it for minutes yeah
my friend Rekha actually is this funny
this is funny true story I don't know
she owns the Space Jam tumbler calm if
you go to that and that's her tumbler
okay check out Jordans friends tumbler
don't do that and we're something
different right now epiphany a moment
when you suddenly become conscious of
something very important showbiz about
who you know my goal is to get the same
representation as IVA Cottle's
they're everywhere that was an epiphany
in history hi I'm Hannah Dickinson this
is cheer see you where I'm kicking off
my first round of the weekend by
cheering all the people and stories that
encouraged me to drink cheers to you
stormy Daniels on the details of trumps
toad wiener it's like how else would I
know that besides just looking at him
cheers to you Bristol Palin for saying
former Teen Mom star Farrah Abraham's is
searching for attention no
cheers to you Justin Bieber for
serenading Haley Baldwin in front of
Buckingham Palace I can't think of any
way to top that except maybe a shower
cheers to you Kylie Jenner for trying
milk with cereal for the first time ever
way to finally make use of that silver
spoon in your mouth I'm jealous
cheers to you Los Angeles for being a
great host to the show this week and
also cheers to my hotel pool for being
the only thing to get me wet thanks a
lot
I don't think we should just be so quick
to bail on people and just like be mean
to them I do have in the comments if
you've been ever been someone been mean
to you if you've ever been someone be
mean to you alright guys so since this
is our 50th episode and you know it's a
special la week I wanted to do something
nice for you guys and so I got you a
little present you know don't get too
excited
these are paperback copies of my book
not quite a genius which is available
for purchase you know I know that I'm
kind of like an inspiration to all you
guys that you really like look up to me
you're welcome you're welcome you're
welcome you're welcome I already spent
money on the hardback so I needed this
man I got a table that's a little wobbly
honestly I'm like a minimalist these
days so I'm trying to like give away
things that don't spark joy in my heart
okay so thank you so much okay that
that's hurtful I'm gonna read it on the
plane all right I like Brian the best
right now are you ready oh you already
did thank you Natasha
okay if I read books I would 100%
[Music]